what have you got in here sometimes it's
the smallest of things that hold the
most value
here we have the keys to grenfell
i just like it because like it's nice to
have like these were my keys to my house
so
you can see that like it was kind of
like burnt
sarah lost everything in the grenfell
fire but nothing compares to the loss of
her family
five of her family members died the
youngest medi was just eight years old
his everyday items are now prized
possessions
i have a bunch of marbles from mehdi's
house and you can see that they're
kind of they're not really shiny anymore
but i guess that's okay
it's impossible to imagine the trauma
this young girl has been through i don't
really like to go outside anymore
and um
yeah i just i don't know it just put me
in a little bit of a dull kind of
setting
you feel like what you're less energy
and your mood's a bit different
yeah most people think i'm being like
annoying or rude or something but it's
not that it's just
i just haven't got the energy sarah's
family are among the 72 people who died
in the tower five years ago
since then almost one and a half
thousand children have been treated for
trauma and the demand isn't going away
the doctor in charge says many children
have been left questioning their sense
of safety bonfire night can feel quite
triggering for people even you know
candles on a birthday cake happen some
people being quite triggering people
feeling you know a bit worried about you
know electrics in the home
and and feeling like they need to check
that things are switched off and just
being kind of hyper aware of safety in a
way that
most
children don't have to be but not all
children want therapy here in this
setting many many more rely on
grassroots organizations for support and
in this community they get it
at this charity they believe in the
power of play using art and activities
to help children grieve cope and begin
to heal
after the grandfather fire we went as
many children that were suffering
significant trauma but this really
ranged you know some children were
becoming very introverts and they didn't
want to talk to anybody and then some
children you could just see it and their
anger and their aggression that's how
they were expressing their trauma and
their sadness and i think that the only
way that you can compare that is to when
you're in the water and you're living
somewhere and then you just got to be
whisked away to a safe country so it was
like that so children were coming to us
and they had suffered you know beyond
trauma it was awful
for sean and his team grenfell was
something they felt personally a family
they supported died in the fire they
keep the memory of them alive in a
special legacy funding trips to
disneyland paris offering children an
escape from a reality which still haunts
them
because for hundreds of children what
happened on the 14th of june 2017 will
always be with them charlotte lomas sky
news